foreign
several summers ago I woke up and
started scrolling through social media
like so many of us do every morning
but what caught my eye that morning
though was an article about how a
hundred thousand people in Detroit were
about to have to live without running
water because they couldn't afford their
water bills
and people have been living with this
issue for a while and they get by they
were doing everything from collecting
rain water and barrels to walking to
relative's houses to take showers every
few days
and much worse sometime later I learned
that a lot of people were actually
losing custody of their kids because
they couldn't afford to pay their water
bills instead of someone helping them
they just lost their kids
for many of them their greatest
transgression You could argue
was that they were either elderly
disabled
had just been laid off
or worked jobs that simply didn't pay
enough and yes I said jobs
and to me how they were being treated
and the level of contempt shown to them
and how easy it was to Simply deny them
something that we all need to live
was disgusting
it's disgusting
but to me this also felt personal even
though I have no direct Family Ties to
Detroit
and here's why
many of the people who were facing
shutoffs were black
many were also like myself black women
and Lord knows it's not the first time
in the United States that black people
have been denied basic human rights like
water
so to me that created an overwhelming
urge to do something to help
I mean I couldn't just read that and
then go on about my day
then it became a question of what can I
sitting in my pajamas is one person at
home actually do
well what oh oh but but wait
I'm a programmer
and a heavy heavy social media user
so I decided to tweet to tweet what I
was reading about what I was seeing how
I felt so my online community of
activists politicians startup Founders
and investors some like yourselves
and other programmers of course
and over the course of a few hours of
back and forth about what to do we
resolved to do the simplest most obvious
thing that would help somebody in this
situation
we decided to pay some water bills
to do that I skipped work that day I did
not go to work that day and instead I
spent a few hours digging around on the
Water Company's website
and I found something interesting that
sort of jump started what to do for
people
for some reason there was a 400 page PDF
of customers on the website that the
water company couldn't deliver their
bills to through the mail
and some of you use word delinquent
accounts but one of the things that was
interesting about this list is that it
also included account numbers for people
so you could just take one of those
account numbers and at that time plug it
into the website and see everything
about that account so I did that
and one of the things that was
interesting though there was that I saw
a make a payment button
so the idea then became what if we
got the account numbers of people that
needed help and then made payments for
them
so a few hours later I built a website
to find those people
and start connecting them to people that
needed help
and then I tweeted that
and to keep things simple
people who wanted to help simply would
get instructions on how to log on to the
utilities website as if they were the
account holder and just make payments
and then once they had done that they
would send us the receipts and we would
send those to the families that had
gotten the help
and empowered with those donations with
those payments they were able to go to
the water company and advocate for
themselves and demand that their water
be turned back on
and in doing that
that's how in the first 40 or so days of
doing this
we paid over a hundred thousand dollars
in water bills by just simply
thank you
by just simply sending people directly
to the utility company's website to pay
five dollars ten dollars
whatever they could afford
and I don't say that to brag but instead
to encourage you all to notice problems
and to think about what is the simplest
most obvious thing you can do to impact
that problem
so first what I'll also say that was
true for us is that it should be
abundantly clear that whatever you do
doesn't actually have to be perfect
you don't have to do some big
overarching thing like a non-profit
because you won't have all the answers
when you start but what's beautiful
about that is that you don't actually
need to have all the answers to get
started
and I will confess that if we had had
all the answers if we had known too much
we may have actually gotten started
so the next thing that's true is that
when you put together and you start
doing something that's imperfect in
Finnish it's not finished
people will see what you're doing and
they'll want to join you
they want to get together with you to
make what you're doing bigger more
impactful more meaningful
but all in ways unique to themselves
for us that was the city employees who
answered our emails on weekends
and then during the week drove people to
appointments to get their water turned
back on
it was the people in mutual Aid groups
and non-profits that partner with us to
completely pay off the water bills for
some families
it was the people who actually really
made this work possible
by giving five dollars ten dollars
twenty dollars some of whom had been in
this situation themselves a few years
prior where they couldn't afford their
own bills but they now could so they
were generous about it
it was the people who held bake sales
to help people that they didn't know and
would never meet
people will see you walking the walk
and they'll understand that that
compassion is contagious
so I'd ask you in this moment then
what is it
that sends you down a rabbit hole of
blog posts and news articles what leaves
you so disgusted and annoyed that you
would rather skip work or class and work
on that instead
what is that for you
it's got to be something
so suppose for example
you find out that the third graders at
your old elementary school owe lunch
money debt what if the most obvious
thing to do for them is to pay off that
lunch money debt sponsor some lunches
and then later on
go run for the local school board to
push for systemic change around access
to nutrition at school
that's just an idea
now you might hear this and say that's
nice it's cute but I don't really have
time for that
or most problems are too big to work on
so why bother
oh so you're not unique in thinking that
at all
but if we just stick with the idea of
doing the smallest at first the most
obvious thing
and just think about for a second what
do you have the time what do you have
the resources
what do you have the skills and the
influence even to do
to make happen
for me I was a programmer with a whole
day job so I didn't actually initially
have time to work on this all day either
but using the skills and the resources
and the network that I did have we built
out the original website and then grew
it from there
so the next somewhat obvious but I think
Hasty criticism that we sometimes hear
is that what we did was just a Band-Aid
that whatever you end up doing is not
going to be significant enough it's not
going to make a difference it's not
going to it's too fleeting
of a thing to try to do to make a
difference
but is it not that the purpose of a
Band-Aid is to give an injury a place
where something has gone wrong the
opportunity to heal
they'll say no initially we weren't
going to solve the root of why people
couldn't afford their water bills
and I'm not here to tell you either that
benevolent strangers sitting at home in
their pajamas are a proper substitute
for systemic structural changes to
issues
but what I will tell you though
is that are also our our solution didn't
attack the poverty it didn't attack the
unemployment it didn't attack the bad
public policy yes bad public policy that
enthusiastically punishes people who are
poor especially when they are black or
brown
but what we did give people
yes well we did give people in that
moment is relief
so again whatever you do if it's small
and if it's an obvious thing it doesn't
mean that your impact can't actually be
durable
and that you shouldn't try to do
something
and I say that because today we have
helped over 5 000 people with water bill
payments just from
thank you
just from people again giving five
dollars ten dollars fifty dollars
whatever they can afford to contribute
and our ripples of compassion have
actually gone even further
we got a major American city to start
offering more compassionate assistance
we had a U.S member of Congress in their
office reach out to get help for their
constituents
we've had policy makers in three
different states
that we were able to help using our data
our knowledge our experience to
understand what's happening around water
affordability in their districts
we've also been able to partner with
other non-profits and mutual Aid groups
to keep families from facing eviction
and homelessness over their water bills
we've also been able to help families
avoid facing the threat of losing their
kids
I also now do this work full time with
the goal of helping utilities understand
how to make water more affordable make
water more of a human right
so that people also don't fall behind on
their bills in the first place
legendary comedian Lily Tomlin once said
always wondered why people wouldn't do
something about that
why somebody wouldn't do something about
that
then I realized I was somebody
so you don't even actually have to be a
programmer to make a difference or even
do what I did
you just have to be like Lily said to be
somebody somebody who sees a thing that
can be fixed can be impacted
and do that do something
thank you
foreign